alors on va retrouver tout de suite le
gilet jaune à jerome rodriguez qui ait
participé à une contre manifestation
aujourd'hui une mobilisation parallèle à
celle de génération identitaire qui a
manifesté depuis la place denfert
rochereau contre volonté de dissolution
de la part du ministre de l'intérieur
jours avoue jérôme rodriguez merci
d'être en direct avec nous vous avez été
interpellé
dites nous ce qui s'est passé vous étiez
du côté de montparnasse vous avez vous
participé à cette contre manifestation
aujourd'hui alors dans l'absolu j'ai
même pas eu le temps d'y participer à
savoir qu'à mon arrivée sur la place
maréchal juin j'avais déjà eu un premier
contrôle de la part de la police
et le plus incroyable c'est qu'ils nous
ont laissé passer et accéder à la place
quelques minutes après j'entends dans
les talkie walkie mon nom résonnait
comme quoi mama ma position est signalé
à l'ensemble des forces de police on
leur répond dans le talkie walkie que
oui oui on l'a bien en vue trois minutes
après vous avez la brave qui débarque et
qui veut une fois de plus
nous verbaliser nous nous maltraiter
nous empêcher de manifester bref
d'appliquer cette discrimination
politique aujourd'hui dont je suis
victime et dont l'ensemble des citoyens
en colère et gilet jaune sont victimes
aujourd'hui discrimination politique
vous avez été interpellé pour refus de
vous soumettre à un contrôle policier ou
rébellion également vous confirmer alors
rébellion quand on lève les bras au ciel
je ne vois pas où est la rébellion dans
un premier temps maintenant aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans un pays qui s'appelle
la france nous avons la liberté de
pouvoir manifester la liberté de pouvoir
s'exprimer aujourd'hui je suis persona
non grata dans paris j'ai un ennemi qui
s'appelle monsieur l'allemand et qui
prend plaisir à chaque fois de vouloir
m'arrêter de vous empêcher de parler à
l'échelle de loyer vous passiez des
reportages sur la russie vis-à-vis
d'opposants politiques
je suis dit exactement la même chose de
la part du gouvernement c'est qu'on veut
me faire taire on veut à tout prix me
renvoyer chez moi donc c'est
qu'apparemment quelque part je gêne en
tant qu'opposant politique et ça
commence à devenir assez désagréable
donc comment donner des leçons à
d'autres pays et appliquer exactement la
même chose on évolue en france il faut
qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble des français
qui est qu'ils vous regardent
comprennent que on se fait arrêter pour
rien simplement du fait que je m'appelle
jérôme rodriguez c'est que j'ai l'air de
gêner la politique que mac on veut
mettre en place aujourd'hui le vous avez
été placé en garde à vue vous êtes libre
là au moment se parlant je suis libre je
vais être reconvoquée en audition libre
à savoir que j'ai été violenté pendant
mon
une interpellation j'ai trois jours
d'itt été déclaré par le médecin ils
m'ont fait mal aux mains ils m'ont
excusez moi mais écrasé les testicules
pendant pendant l'arrestation et quoi
qu'il arrive nous allons porter plainte
à la fois pour violences policières
séquestration et est comment dire
atteinte à la liberté de enfin atteinte
à ma liberté tout simplement trois ans
policière 14 juillet de de subir vous
parlez de violences policières avant
trouvait pas sans l'autre rencontre ça
c'est le jeu c'est quand votre
interpellation ou après exactement oui
exactement
c'est un moment donné on may cry des
testicules jugés sûrs qu'on me l'écraser
je donne le herriot de la personne qui
le fait voilà mais de toute façon quoi
qu'il advienne c'est la brave m il faut
savoir que la brave m passe son temps à
m'insulter à me menacer de me faire le
deuxième oeil
donc voilà ça ne m'étonne même pas de
leur part ils ont une dent contre moi
moi j'ai un oeil contre eux donc à mon
aîné on sera jamais amis avec ce genre
de jeu de personnes ne sont pas des
policiers
c'est une milice politique qui est juste
là à protéger les intérêts d'un
gouvernement et non pas se mettre au
service du citoyen pour pouvoir les
protéger ce sont des gens qui sont au
service du maintien du désordre et non
pas au maintien de l'ordre
donc aujourd'hui il faut arrêter avec
ces voltigeurs quand on sait que par le
passé ils ont su tuer des gens qu'est ce
qu'on attend
on va recommencer on attend qu'il ya un
mort de la part de cette police pendant
sa suite au venir à des préceptes du
maintien et non pas des préceptes
violent du maintien du désordre
on rappelle que qu'à la suite de la
faire de votre épargne mans lors d'une
manifestation de gilet jaune
deux policiers ont été mises en examen
est ce que vous vous faites un lien
entre ce qui vous est arrivé aujourd'hui
et cette affaire vous savez le souci
aujourd'hui c'est que dès que vous
faites un lien on va vous traiter de
complotiste et moi je n'ai pas trop
envie si vous voulez de rentrer dans ce
jeu déjà ce que de là à dire qu'on
cherche à m'abattre
ouais contre moi c'est pas facile
d'avoir deux collègues aujourd'hui mises
en garde à vue enfin du moins mise en
examen donc je pense qu'il ya une part
de vengeance d'une certaine partie de la
police attention je fais bien la
différence entre la police que
très content aujourd'hui au sein des
manifestations et la police du quotidien
voyez j'ai été très bien accueilli c'est
paradoxal de dire ça dans le
commissariat où j'ai eu ma garde à vue
quoi j'ai des messages de sympathie les
policiers sont très courtois très poli
avec moi chose qui n'a rien à voir avec
justement la brave m
donc je pense que oui il ya une part de
vengeance vous savez quand on s'amuse à
éborgné gratuitement au sein des
manifestations et conquis son complice
de cela ça les ennuie quand un collègue
à eux se fait arrêter non seulement
alors pour terminer jérôme rodriguez
était donc aux côtés des
contre-manifestants aujourd'hui qui se
sont rassemblés face à cette
mobilisation de génération identitaire
qui est menacée de dissolution par un
gérald darmanin dans quel camp vous
situer précisément et que pensez vous de
cette intention de dissoudre génération
identitaire vous savez je suis pour la
liberté de parole on est dans un pays
qui s'appelle la démocratie il faut que
chacun puisse avoir la liberté de
pouvoir s'exprimer je ne suis carrément
pas d'accord avec les idées que peuvent
représenter génération identitaire mais
carrément pas aimer je pense qu'il est
important de pouvoir les laisser parler
pour que nous on puisse les contrées
autour d'un débat verbalement de dire
que ce qu'il raconte c'est mauvais que
c'est pas bon que parce que je pense que
ce type de personnes racistes fascistes
sont beaucoup plus dangereuses quand
elles font silence parce que le joug si
elles réussissent en tout cas leur
projet ça risque de nous éclater à la
tronche donc moi je préfère les entendre
et les contrées par la voix et les
contrées par deux les billets le biais
de manifestations quand eux manifestent
aujourd'hui faut juste se poser la
question comment ça se fait que la
manifestation de fascistes soit
autorisée sur paris et qu'une
manifestation contre justement les
fascistes soit refusé de la part de
didier lallement ce qui nous prouve une
fois de plus que ce dernier a choisi son
camp
et force est de constater que c'est pas
le meilleur quand il est choisi et qui
montre très bien la politique
aujourd'hui contraint de mettre en place
macron merci beaucoup à vous un jérôme
rodriguez y avait aussi une
manifestation d gilet jaune du côté de
lille aussi je sais pas si vous
m'entendez il y avait une manifestation
de gilet jaune aujourd'hui du côté de
lille vous les soutenez bien évidemment
vous êtes un gilet jaune bas il y avait
il y avait une manifestation gilet jaune
à paris à une manifestation gilet jaune
à strasbourg il y avait une
manifestation en gilet jaune à toulouse
à lille comme tous les samedis en france
vous savez bon rtg si vous êtes au
courant parce que vous communiquez super
bien là dessus mais sur l'ensemble des
autres médias les gilet jaune n'existe
plus et pourtant ils sont encore le
samedi dans la rue forcément quand y'a
pas d'actes de violence chose que je ne
dénonce pas de nous donc voila mais en
tout cas on est bien présent et je tiens
à apporter mon soutien à l'ensemble des
gilet jaune qui tiennent le terrain pour
ne serait ce par entendre le plus
pacifiquement possible l'ensemble de nos
revendications
merci beaucoup à vous j'ai demeuré gaz
pour cette intervention directe sur rt
france